hello morale on the biggest most strange
expressive peculiar enormous stop-motion
film I thing that's ever been made
everything is created everything is
handmade 57 different scents it's been
formed in 3d Coraline is the story of a
little girl and Coraline Jones who lives
in a large house and has been turned
into flats it has a door was locked when
she gets her mother to unlock it it
opens onto a brick wall brick Oh gates
one day she opens the door and it's not
brings its Accardo and she goes down it
and she finds herself somewhere that
looks just like house she left
only just ever so slightly different
it's a little bit order and waiting for
her her other mother and her other
father in the book you pretty much know
it's creepy from the outset it's
interesting and it's much cooler in some
ways in the world she's left but you
really don't want her to stay there and
when she has to go back you know it's a
really scary thing to be doing there's
one tiny little thing we need to do no I
wrote Coraline it hadn't even got
published yet I gave it to my agent and
said can you get this down or eise Alec
Henry read it called me up said I want
to do this and it took Henry that would
have been 2001 so it took Henry seven
years to get his film made essentially
Henry just took story and expanded it he
created this kid who YB who turns up a
few times who's really just their
assembly the coraline too talkative
because part of the story is that the
adults aren't talking to ma I'm really
really busy there's nobody really
talking to us so she's off exploring the
world herself I started it for my
daughter Holly when she was 4 or 5
because she would come home from her
kindergarten and she'd see me writing
and she would climb up on my lap and she
would dictate stories they would
normally involve a little girl who would
come home to find that her mother was
not actually her mother but now an evil
witch and she would get imprisoned in
basements locked up and she would have
to escape I used to work a lot through
the night when I was writing Sandman
and quite often I'd to the look up and
there will be a small child in the
doorway so I used to just make a space
for them under my desk and Holly or Mike
would come in at two o'clock three
o'clock in the morning and they'd sit
under my desk and draw and write for a
bit then go back to bed the joy I think
of something like this is I get write a
book right now Henry Selick gets to go
make a movie p craig russell got to take
caroline and he turned it into a graphic
novel stephen merit the magnetic fields
in the Gothic arches is currently taking
Caroline him he's turning it into a
musical that he's going to do and
they're all inspired by the book but I'm
not telling any of them what to do I
just stand there and go this is really
cool of people are making art and it's
inspired by something really weird that
I did
you